so boots when we hear about the epics of
the 1950s and 60s we'll say ten years in
the making but this was ten years in the
making and you were gonna make it into a
song first right yeah well I just I
didn't remember that at the time but
looking back recently in some of my old
notebooks because that's what I do and I
don't have anything to write I'm like oh
maybe an old idea I can steal for myself
and I found that in like 2001 I had
written a single line that was a concept
for a song that was you know me as a
telemarketer selling slaves and so I
mean that's the kind of you know in a
way this is even crazier then the movie
but I yeah so obvious I didn't remember
that that's the first where the idea was
but then later in 2011 I sat down to to
actually start writing it for the
producers for Nina and for Charles and
for George each of you tries to bring
into mainstream and into films aspects
of life people voices that would not be
heard otherwise so tell us about your
experience of this film coming to you
and what your aha moment was my aha
moment is always seeking filmmakers of
color that has a unique voice something
that we haven't seen in the marketplace
so that's what drop me and for sweared
occur to it and you were producer
Fruitvale station yes I am Charles what
what was your epiphany about this well I
was fortunate to meet this this man
boots Reilly at one of the Sundance labs
and I was just captivated by his vision
for this project and then I also wanted
to be in business with this one right
here because I know what a great
producer she was I said hey we could if
I had an opportunity to work with the
two of them then we were definitely on
board and and George you do
Entertainment Law as well
yeah I'm based in San Francisco and
every year a host
yoky holiday contests and boots showed
up I was I was aware of who he was
because of the coup and his activism and
stuff and you know I was actually a
little intimidated I thought it'd be
very serious but he's saying still rock
and roll to me by Billy Joel anyone the
most inspirational trophy and while he's
walking out the door he handed me the
script and I was sold look Keith you
were in get out and you think how can I
match that what can I look for how did
they approach you with this script and
say this is your next big thing
um boots put it very plainly to me you
didn't get out do it again no ok yeah
get out wasn't even now it was it was
just uh I was at Sundance dancing around
in the Sun and there was a strange man
with an afro and mutton chops who was
following me around with oh it was boots
sorry and once I took the pages from him
and read it I realized after a while
that this was something that was very
special and could be an opportunity to
explore a character that hadn't explored
before and tell a story that I hadn't
seen been to been told before and so I
was very excited at the opportunity that
we might be able to make something out
of this crazy thing I'd been looking for
an opportunity to sort of mix it up and
challenge myself and hopefully audiences
and so I thought this was a great
opportunity also to have conversations
about difficult topics and difficult
things to talk about sometimes it's
easier to come up with a disposition
about a thing and when you're seeing it
through art Terry Crews you're the king
of all media you can do anything you
want so I got a shot of that
[Laughter]
you you keep at it I'll come right back
to your pouting so so how how were you
approached for this role and you take a
lot of persuading first of all I have to
give it up to Nina
Bon Jovi because we met uh I was I was
introduced to her and she was so excited
I about this project I got this movie
you won't believe boots Riley and I new
boots and and I also had met the Keith
oh I like a year and a half two years
earlier and I said man I want to work
with you one thing about always been a
big fan but her energy her love she was
like you gotta see this you got it and I
said okay okay I looked at it and I was
like what in the world what and I kept
flipping pages like oh what what and
when I got to the end I would have paid
boots to be in the movie because I said
there's no way I said when do I show up
I will do a free whatever I'll hand out
stuff I'll do security we got to make
sure this gets done and then all then
all the other names started coming in I
didn't even know about all the other
giant names that were in here but again
with her energy and her love for it I
mean that's what a producer is all about
and then like Heath being that catalyst
who I knew would be the future of what
this town is all about this man has got
so much coming it's incredible
Patton Oswalt when did you come on board
as the voice of the mysterious man in
the bowler hat in the wyatt earp
mustache I feel like I came on board
years ago kay let me read the screenplay
years ago and I could in the screenplay
it's the same quality when I read it as
listening to the COO which is the COO my
writing partner I always said it's the
worst music - right - because your
constant wait would rewind that what the
hell like you you're you're it takes you
out of whatever you're working on it's
so dense and amazing and the script when
I the first time you showed it to me I
kept stopping on what in the I would go
back which I've always heard as a script
should not have that quality but I was
and
actually one thing makes me wonder
because I was river reading going I just
want to see this movie just to see if he
can pull these visuals off I remember
reading going how is he going to shoot
what he's describing so that that is
what so I just said I remember telling
you I don't care what you want me to do
in this movie if you ever get this made
I'm in I'll do whatever you tell me then
and Patton came on when there was no
producers yet no money no nothing and I
definitely used his name to the fullest
this film has elements of Fable its
political parody in some ways was it the
film you started out with how much did
it change when I started out I was like
I know I'm gonna make a film that will
be in the telemarketing world and I know
that he's gonna have to there's gonna be
a struggle that he has to decide what
side he's on I knew that I knew the
first scene because that's my friend Rob
ebo that's how he always got his jobs
and he never got caught and then and and
I knew the compliment argument scene
because that happened to my little
brother some years ago and I was always
like I'm gonna put that in a movie one
day and so I that's all I knew but and
then the rest I took the journey with
Cash's I mean I had things that I wanted
to do I wanted there to be a I wanted
there to be a character a black
character that wasn't only thinking
about survival and you know how to make
it through the jungle of other black
people like so many movies are I wanted
it to be what humans do someone that
thinks about himself in the context of
time and space and is thinking about
their existence because I think that's
what all humans doing for me having that
in there I knew that would make him more
human and understandable and but as I
went on see so for me a lot of my work
even with music has been fighting cliche
and I realized that we lean towards
shei all the time because we've seen so
many movies and heard so many songs that
it's hard to parse out what our real
experience is in life from what we saw
in a movie so for instance I've never
been a deli in India I have a clear
picture in my head of deli with the
transportation and the the clothing and
what the streets look like I haven't
even seen a documentary about Delhi all
that stuff is from James Bond movies or
something like that and so if I were to
sit down and write a scene happening in
Delhi it would have not only cliches but
probably very racist things that you
know have to do with that and so when
I'm writing a scene it's all about me
trying it or or anything it's me trying
to figure out parse out what I believe
based on my own experience is me
interrogating myself and based on the
things that I believe that aren't from
you know another movie so I'm you know
for me a lot of that has to do with my
larger ideas about the world and so how
do you have a philosophical idea
injected into a scene do you have
somebody say well you know message
message message no hopefully not and
then do you you know you can come up
with all sorts of contrivances but what
I found and this is just this is how the
weird [ __ ] started getting in there was
like I found that the way that I that
that the way that worked to put those
ideas in in order to keep it more real
in my viewpoint from my experience was
to bend the reality of the world in the
movie and so I didn't set out to make
something weird and stuff like that but
it was it was needed I needed the equi
sapiens there for him to see what he
what it was because I had written the
the rap performance and I thought that
was gonna be the thing for him to see
himself but I was like that doesn't make
sense that that's enough there's slavery
going on and he's selling slaves
and everybody accepts all that so all of
these things were stuff that was new it
had to feel real to me so that that's
the part that changed the other you know
there were other things that changed
especially in the Sundance labs but
mainly around him around me making him
take ownership of his choices
the code-switching elements of this are
familiar to you but they may be really
new to an audience the idea that oh my
god you have to speak in a different
voice to get in different groups to
listen to you so as as you developed
your own characters what did you draw on
I don't think it's that unfamiliar if
you think about it
code switching is something that we all
do to survive in many forms and fashions
and I think the white voice here could
be representative of a lot of different
things not simply just a voice in a way
that sounds over the phone but how we
make ourselves look to others how we
dress ourselves up and pretty little
things and things we do to make
ourselves more palatable particularly in
the workplace and I think everyone that
is involved in that game to one level or
another because it's important to be and
it's has been important for our survival
for years to have that so if you look at
it more as a metaphor everyone is
experiencing that to some degree so I
think it is it's a universal theme and
so I just I really tried to pay less
attention to the implications behind and
more attention to just the idea and then
the ambition that the the character was
experiencing and trying to bring about
change in his life
by any means necessary thereby sometimes
through that overlooking sometimes
friends and family and loved ones in the
process and for Terry know I and I agree
with the Keith and that um it's
definitely the code switching is
something that we all have done in some
way form or fashion but IIIi I think to
define it a little bit better sometimes
code switching sounds like it's some
sort of farce or some kind of game I
think for me it's always survival right
well you know just trying to trick
someone into
selling something or whatever that's my
always saw code-switching being I always
looked at as being bilingual just simply
because I remember being a kid and going
over my white friends houses and I knew
how they lived already simply because
everything was white the media the TV
shows i watch The Brady Bunch
I knew it was like and but then when
they come over my house they didn't
understand what we were saying they had
no clue and they were telling me what
did that mean
what that you get 50 million questions
from your white friends when they come
in your house and you realize oh they
don't know what I'm talking about so I
have to speak their language all the
time if I'm outside I have to speak your
language but there was a lot of times
there was a total unwillingness for them
to learn mine and so you when you talk
about code switching it's about survival
in a lot of ways thank you everybody
please thank the panel